what a lovely surprise here to help us
make it work is Tim Gunn he's got a new
book the natty professor but right now
we're going to make him talk politics
which I suspect he's going to love for a
number of reasons not the least of which
is as we've discussed you've been on
Capitol Hill lobbying I don't know the
fashion you've been very critical of
Washington I have why well first of all
what's wrong with Capitol Hill I believe
in the semiotic long list y know exactly
but I believe in the semiotic sub
clothes the clothes we wear like it or
not sends a message about how the world
perceives us and these are elected
officials they're ambassadors for their
constituents and I look at Leader Nancy
Pelosi incredibly beautifully dressed
and owning her gender and being a
serious role model and mrs. Obama it
doesn't get any better than that
so why can't other women on the hill
follow in their footsteps if only just
to emulate and then when it comes to men
I don't even know what to say well it's
because everything's at least two sizes
too big that's decent it's got to stop
so let's start ted cruz has already
announced what should he have worn when
he spoke at Liberty University well I
have a very particular point of view
about this and I believe in authenticity
I believe that the Republicans writ
large are all hiding behind the uniform
of sorts and I believe I'm I really want
to know who that individual is and what
is Ted who is Ted Cruz when it comes to
choosing his own apparel and accessories
and and even when it comes to grooming I
feel as though this is a rather like the
Hollywood red carpet with stylist that
there are political advisors saying you
will wear this you will wear that you
want to be uncontroversial well I look
at the clothes as being a matter and the
in the current state of just a matter of
blandness or if anything the political
views of the individuals are even more
accentuated and in many cases with these
Republicans you don't want that to
happen so distract me with your clothing
yeah I think maybe people joke around
about it but this matters there's not a
little consultants who are saying you
will wear this you'll wear this tie
you'll wear this
you wear this suit your spouse will wear
this this and this in your experience
how much to the eye of a potential voter
does how Ted Cruz walks out on stage
really have an impact well admittedly I
do have my biases for me it's everything
so Rand Paul Sarah from Kentucky is
expected to be the next Republican in
he's rocked the mock turtleneck every
once in a while
wears jeans more regularly than most
what do you get the sense of what's he
trying to portray when you see that
country boy man of the people
accessibility I believe that that is
within his whole bundle of semiotics
when it comes to the message that his
clothes are sending and quite frankly I
think it's appropriate Chris Christie
from New Jersey tough guys tough guy you
all ready groaning I wouldn't want to be
in a dark alley with him that's for sure
oh I don't think anybody what do you
view if you're chris Christie what's the
what's the image you're trying to
portray
well seriousness reliability honesty and
integrity all things that of course he's
battling and he needs suits that fit him
better and whenever anyone talks about a
larger man and how it's so challenging
look at James Gandolfini may he rest in
peace he looked fantastic in his suits
and Christie looks as though he could
potentially go into Walmart and search
shoplifting and no one would be able to
tell you have been particularly hard on
Secretary of State Hillary Clinton I
passed I hated them right I have been
very critical of angel changing it to oh
I have done a 180-degree about-face on
mrs. Clinton is looking exceptionally
presidential and what pleases me so much
is that she does understand semiotic s--
she clearly gets it when she was the
first lady I saw this enormous arc of
growth happened in terms of her personal
style in fashion she entered the White
House I thought were other frumpy I felt
that she exited as an angel of fashion
when she became the senator from New
York I thought okay she's the senator
from New York this is a license to do
anything
and she disappointed me to be honest now
I have to say a Secretary of State I you
couldn't pay me enough money to have
that position in fact she may look at
the presidency and think I'll feel
physically lighter for being a president
not being Secretary of State yet
so I forgave her a lot of her fashion
foibles because she was wait 24/7 and
constantly flying around a meeting and
greeting I don't think she'd be
surprised if she had time to change your
underwear
one last question that's why I let you
go and this is important cowboy boots
they are an accessory that is being
rocked by no shortage of Republican
candidates even more perhaps democratic
added spending on the state you go to
your view cowboy boots I think there are
too much of a stereotype and I feel it's
too forced and contrived and old hat and
it doesn't impress me even remote like
what if you're from Texas
it impresses me less not that you have
anything against Texas I heard recently
that they want to secede from the union
I think there's been a steady thing for
the Tim Gunn you are a fashion
connoisseur you are an author you are an
advocate you're a darn good Capitol Hill
lobbyist from what I've heard thanks
you're all makers and aides
I want to thank you very much for coming
in we have already ordered our copies of
the nati professor Tim we will see you
next time and we'll be right back
you